they've come to seek work in Britain
it's been 75 years since the Empire
Windrush sailed to the docks of Tilbury
they begin their new life over here and
on it around 500 Caribbean men women and
children about to shape the course of
British history
seven decades later descendants of those
first pioneers retrace their steps I
truly believe that we can carry this on
and carry on a legacy for our children
and their children
so yeah it makes me feel really proud
they came because they were invited
answering a call from the motherland to
help build the country back after two
world wars
ADI pass was among them a veteran who
moved from Jamaica to Bristol in 1968
and today he celebrated from an event in
Wales
they're on
extraordinary
group of people who have contributed so
much
the king who was born the year the ship
arrived also recognized the defining
moment in history
in London celebrations kicked off at
Waterloo Station where thousands of
Caribbean migrants would have once to
pass through
representatives of the pioneering
generation embarked on a walk to a
service in their honor
to remember the history but also to
acknowledge the livelihoods that have
been threatened by the ongoing Windrush
scandal
it's easy to celebrate and get carried
away and have a party and have a good
time but actually the most important
thing is that people need to be
compensated but they also need their
status and whilst the past and present
struggles were acknowledged the
contribution was the main focus of the
day whether that be the food the clothes
the music all of which is becoming part
of mainstream Society I have a
granddaughter that's going to be
arriving the first 2nd of July hopefully
and I want her to know what that
generation gave
today wasn't just about the first
arrivals or the thousands that followed
it was also an opportunity for the
hundreds of thousands of winrich
descendants to celebrate those who paved
the way shiman Freeman Powell Sky News